aujourd'hui alors que vous avez eu le
courage de dénoncer ce qui s'est passé
vous seriez poursuivi pour
non-assistance à personne en danger euh
ça c'est pour pour vous juste c'est fou
euh concrètement on vous reproche quoi
parce que vous êtes venu dans l'émission
et puis il y a pas que vous il y a votre
tente à un moment qui a été venu pareil
elle est poursuivie pour non assistance
à personne en danger et vous on va dire
pourquoi vous êtes poursuivi dans un
instant Brian vous Justin qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce que vous reproche on me
reproche justement de pas avoir dénoncé
alors que j'ai justement aidé à dénoncer
tout ce qui se passait et maintenant on
m'incuse de ne pas l'avoir fait assez
tôt comment ça s'est matérialiser cette
accusation qu'est-ce qui vous a dit qui
vous a dit
en fait on a j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone en me demandant de venir en
tant que témoin pour l'histoire de la
bagarre avec le frère de 16 ans donc
j'ai été etc et au niveau de la fin de
l'audition l'inspectrice me demande si
j'ai vu des coups ou entendu des
insultes donc je réponds oui je les ai
vu je les ai entendus et à partir de ce
moment là elle me dit bah écoutez vous
êtes
non accusé de non-assistance à personne
en danger donc de là elle m'a fait une
audition libre
c'est quand même incroyable que vous
soyez sur le banc des accusés dans cette
affaire et c'est vrai que
à nos yeux on est face à une énorme
injustice Gigante c'est sidérant c'est à
dire que vous dénoncez un scandale vous
dénoncez des sévices à une fratrie alors
que toutes les instances n'ont rien fait
vous voilà sur le banc des accusés alors
moi j'ai une question à vous poser
depuis le début de la faire on a
l'impression que la justice ne vous
croit pas trop le procureur était très
en retrait etc
on va parler de Brian après oui voilà
oui on va revenir sur l'affaire si vous
pouviez résumer l'affaire à nous
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent et
bien donc cette dans le nord de la
France une maison de l'horreur comme on
dit effroyable avec des enfants qui sont
ligotés sur des sièges c'est
insupportable des sévices des coups
portés vous dénoncez ça et puis
finalement vos parents
semblent très légèrement
sans protéger par la justice je vais le
dire clairement on a l'impression qu'ils
sont protégés et puis là maintenant ça
se retourne donc Justine et Bryan est-ce
que réellement
la justice ne vous croit pas et est-ce
que la justice finalement n'a pas envie
d'élucider cette affaire tout à fait
c'est ça moi je le prends comme ça vous
sentez comme ça oui tout à fait parce
qu'à l'heure actuelle on ne parle pas de
prison pour ces personnes
au contraire on dit qu'il récupèreont
peut-être les enfants en septembre 2023
donc si les récupère c'est que pour moi
il y aura pas tout simplement et je ne
sais même pas comment on peut mettre des
enfants après tout ce qui s'est passé là
dedans on vous fait payer le fait
d'avoir parlé sur notre plateau c'est ça
on nous fait payer le fait d'avoir parlé
et dénoncer tout ce qui se passait sur
les différents plateaux d'ailleurs que
vous avez fait ça mission si vous
n'aviez pas témoigné vous ne seriez pas
inquiété c'est ça donc en fait ce qu'on
vous demande c'est le silence tout à
fait
vous regrettez de l'avoir fait non
non je regarde pas d'avoir parlé ce que
je pense que à l'heure actuelle c'est
important que les gens savent et surtout
les enfants que ben il faut se battre en
fait pour avoir justice malheureusement
et peut-être on l'aura pas mais j'espère
que ça finira par se faire et que les
enfants qui le vivent et qui n'osent pas
dénoncer le front et que eux aussi
auront justice on va parler de ce qui
arrive à Bryan dans un instant vous
allez voir aussi c'est hallucinant c'est
encore plus grave que pour que pour
Justine puisque Justine vous vous êtes
poursuivi pour non-assistance à personne
en danger et quand on réunit les les
deux chefs d'accusation que ce soit pour
Justine et pour Brian vous allez voir
que il y a quand même une certaine
incohérence Gilles où on est aujourd'hui
cette affaire au niveau de la justice
cette affaire elle n'avance pas c'est à
dire que vous aviez demandé la garde ça
vous a été refusé
Cyril la justice n'y croit pas en fait
c'est ça c'est que la justice ne croit
pas à votre témoignage la justice ne
croit pas au service la justice ne croit
pas que ses enfants étaient battus et
c'est incroyable parce que vous aviez
des éléments c'était étayé et puis on a
l'impression que finalement on n'a pas
envie que ça aille au bout comment vous
vous vivez ça est-ce que vous ressentez
une profonde injustice Bryan c'est
totalement une injustice parce que la
justice elle nous croit pas quand
j'étais au loco de police on me dit on a
déjà vu pire
on a déjà vu pire aujourd'hui on me dit
que si comme Justine Naji septembre 2023
c'est mes parents répondre aux
obligations qui sont aujourd'hui si tout
se passe bien récupérer les enfants
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que ça va
comment commencer je sais que mon frère
de 16 ans lui il va plus retourner
là-bas on refuse la garde de mes frères
et sœurs parce que j'ai eu des soucis
avec la justice il y a il y a deux ans
des soucis pourquoi je me bagarrer dans
la rue des refus d'obtempérer avec la
police et bagarre multiple j'ai eu des
condamnations j'ai fait mes peines moi
quand quand j'ai fait preuve de violence
on m'a envoyé directement en prison j'ai
pris ça oui totalement je l'ai toujours
dit moi j'ai ce que vous aviez une haine
en vous c'était c'est quoi c'était
c'était
parce que j'ai grandi dedans après j'ai
eu des mauvaises fréquentations
mais de la base qui finit comme ça
j'étais condamné à deux ans de prison
j'avais eu lieu sur site ça j'ai pas
respecté moi directement ma puni dès que
j'ai commis des violences on m'a envoyé
directement en prison aujourd'hui la
justice ne fait pas pareil alors que il
y a justice sur des enfants moi je me
suis a des adultes je regrette tout à
fait tous mes gestes
comme j'ai dit comme je disais pendant
ma peine de prison faut que je paye pour
ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait aujourd'hui
ces gens ne payent pas pour ce qui est
ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui c'est nous
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en train de
payer pour ce qui pour ce qu'ils ont
fait moi aujourd'hui on me on m'accuse
de violence volontaire en réunion parce
que j'ai défendu mon petit frère là la
bagarre du dimanche c'est ça Brian
pourrait se retrouver derrière les
barreaux il pourrait retourner en prison
il est poursuivi pour violence en
réunion pour avoir défendu son frère
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter à
nouveau ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là
lorsque vous avez défendu votre frère
pour qu'on ait bien l'histoire en tête
je vais te raconter au début c'était un
dimanche soir quelques jours plus tôt
j'avais été voir même petit frère et mes
parents me disaient comme quoi ils
allaient à la fête de la ville le
dimanche du coup je dis bah on passera
au soir après la fête qui était assez
tard il était 22h on revenait de chez ma
tante d'un repas avec elle
on va à la botte je sais pas ce qui se
passe normalement je passe normalement
comme habituellement ça parle voilà ça
raconte ça tout ce qu'ils ont fait et
j'ai mon petit frère de 16 ans qui vient
me voir pour m'expliquer comme quoi il y
a ma sœur de de 20 ans qui passait sa
journée à regarder mal sa famille ou une
histoire comme ça après moi je prête pas
attention c'est une histoire entre mon
petit frère ma petite sœur et je vais
pas m'emmêler donc je lui fais
comprendre en gros que c'est pas tout à
fait mon problème quoi je zappe et
de là il va voir ma sœur tout seul avec
il va lui parler elle était dans la
cuisine il a rejoint et ça se parle
calmement au début et là ma sœur tout
d'un coup va prendre un élan
d'agressivité elle va commencer à crier
une sorte d'appel à l'aide pour les
autres et je vois je vois mon père son
comportement pas comme d'habitude alors
nous nous a toujours fait commis des
violences mais il voulait que entre nous
on se remette pas tout le temps quand il
y avait une énorme brouille ou quoi il
venaient séparer directement et là je le
vois au lieu de séparer il va se mettre
derrière mon petit frère il va lui
bloquer une issue Yama sœur en face de
lui en train de lui parler et je vois
mon beau-frère de 20 ans pareil il se
met sur le côté de mon petit frère
et je vois que ça apprend à ton énorme
donc je décide de rejoindre la cuisine
puisque je chantais qui avait c'était
pas bon donc je vais voir ce qui se
passe et tout d'un coup ça crie ça crie
mais pas de violence et mon petit frère
il se fait serrer par mon père par
derrière pour pas d'échappatoire donc
mon petit frère malheureusement le
réflexe cette poussée ma sœur pour pour
s'évacuer tout ça et de là il y a il y a
le beau-frère qui arrive de 20 ans il
m'a un grand coup de poing dans la tête
et s'en va ensuite une bagarre entre les
trois bah entre les quatre les trois
adultes et mon petit frère ou ils sont
en train de lui taper dessus faut savoir
qu'il y a que des deux femmes Justine et
ma mère dans la maison et que des
enfants
mon petit frère 16 ans donc je prends
malheureusement la décision de d'aller
comme eux à l'étape et physiquement donc
je mets des coups de poing des coups de
pied comme eux je suis sur mon petit
frère de là je le dégage on se fait
mettre dehors
et donc le l'homme mon père sort dehors
nous insulte on prête pas attention on
rentre et là on va déposer plainte et
j'explique j'explique ça la justice et
la justice aujourd'hui comme j'ai dit
elle veut pas nous croire ou du moins le
prêter pas attention bizarrement ce qui
s'est passé c'est quand je raconte ça le
jour où je fais porter plainte on me
reproche rien on me dit rien du tout on
me dit c'est normal j'ai bien agi ils
aurai fait comme moi bizarrement là je
fais comment ça à passer sur les
plateaux TV ou sur 7 à 8 ou quoi que ce
soit et je commence malheureusement pour
eux à critiquer la justice expliquer ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire et là une
semaine d'apprendre un coup de fil du
commissariat de police de Lens qui est
qui nous demande de venir et moi ils
mettent en ben il s'appelle ça
mise en cause pour violence volontaire
ensuite tu as juste une qui qui accusé
pour nos instances à personne engagée il
y a tout simplement toutes les personnes
qui sont passées à la télé mais qui a
porté plainte qui a personne c'est le
magistrat qui a décidé après qu'on soit
passé à la télé de revenir sur tous les
points donc lui pour lui maintenant
c'est important de revenir sur tout donc
toi tu es en train de toi tu poursuivi
pour violence en réunion c'est ça on va
défendu ton frère donc vous êtes tous
poursuivis il y a un mois pour violence
en réunion mon petit frère à la base
était victime ils l'ont fait passer en
tant qu'accusé d'accord il y a Justine
ma tante Magali qui était venue ici
ouais c'est ça il y a ma grand-mère tous
ceux qui ont parlé sur cette sur 7 à 8 7
à 8 ou sur TPMP ils sont tous mis en
cause pour nos instances à personne en
danger donc là et vos parents et mes
parents eux ça comme ça ils sont pas
accusés pour plus de choses il n'y a pas
de poursuite non ils sont comme nous
poursuivis pour la bagarre et pour les
enfants
[Musique]
honnêtement on a l'impression qu'elle a
la justice ferme les yeux d'une manière
sidérante j'ai pas vu ça depuis des
années vous avez peur aujourd'hui non
non bizarrement je ne veux pas aller en
prison mais j'ai pas peur parce que
j'aurais tout fait pour ces enfants
c'est à dire que j'aurais fait en sorte
qu'ils sortent de la bague qui ne
souffre plus en fait alors actuelle j'ai
réussi à avoir des nouvelles un peu
comme je peux des enfants qui sont
placés au foyer et il me disent qu'ils
sont beaucoup plus heureux la boxe chez
eux puisque les enfants mineurs ont été
placés mais
ils pourraient être récupéré par vos
parents dans quelques semaines
voilà vous y pensez à ça oui on sait que
ça peut ça peut arriver
quand j'ai déposé mon petit frère au
foyer parce que c'est moi qui l'a fait
j'ai vu leur référence elle m'a dit ne
t'inquiète pas je te donne mon numéro de
téléphone si tu as quoi que ce soit une
demande là on va se débrouiller pour que
tu récupères tes frères et sœurs on va
se débrouiller pour qu'ils vont plus
là-bas on va se débrouiller pour que tu
vois tes frères et sœurs le plus
rapidement possible
aujourd'hui on me dit que si dans un an
tout se passe bien les récupère moi
aujourd'hui ça fait le 30 deux mois que
mais mes frères et sœurs ils sont au
foyer j'ai interdiction de leur parler
que ce soit au téléphone j'ai
interdiction de les voir
de tout faire malheureusement j'essaie
de respecter la justice même si eux pour
moi il me respecte pas ils mettent plus
le scrataire
aujourd'hui il me demande patience mais
au bout d'un moment ma patience elle va
arriver à certaines limites et je serai
obligé de faire contre la justice aller
les voir je pourrais pas rester comme ça
ils me disent de que je pourrais pas
récupérer mon frère pour les sucer avec
la justice que j'ai eu ils veulent pas
que je vois je vois mes frères et sœurs
pour l'instant parce que j'ai fait pas
remédiat parce que je suis venu voir
tout le monde je suis venu crier en gros
scandale à l'aide parce que là justice
elle répond pas et aujourd'hui on me dit
qu'il faut pas voir faut pas que je vole
les petits pour pas que je leur affiche
une
un caractère de revanche avec mes
parents et mon but c'est pas de dire mes
petits frères dans les d'aller se venger
quand mes parents mon but c'est que les
enfants soient en sécurité qui revont
plus la box il les voit pas aujourd'hui
on a demandé à mon petit frère plusieurs
fois si vous voulez revoir mes parents
il y a non mais pour eux le pouce à le
faire lui il veut toujours pas donc
ils veulent le laisser dans le foyer
jusqu'à ses 18 ans surtout ne pas ne pas
le mettre chez moi en gros aujourd'hui
j'ai un peu contre la justice donc on
nous fait payer c'est notre punition
aujourd'hui et d'avoir parlé aux médias
d'avoir parlé à tout le monde
tout ce qui sont en train de faire et
aujourd'hui nous encourait pour nous
punir
aujourd'hui
il serait vraiment en danger pour toi
c'est retourner chez eux
ils seront danger oui ça c'est une
certitude ça va recommencer ils ont le
coup de malice ils savent comment ils
vont faire une nouvelle fois ça va pas
prévenir quand ça va passer et là ce
qu'ils ont bien c'est qu'ils ont la
justice de leur côté les instants
sociales qui qui les protègent donc ça
sera ça sera en danger mais mes parents
seront protégés plus peut-être dans six
ans vous allez recevoir un de mes petits
frères parce que il y en aura un de mort
et puis au job qu'est-ce que les grands
ils ont fait et on dira quoi que la
justice a encore loupé un coup qu'on n'a
pas vu qu'on a c'est pas assez pas assez
prévenu de ce qui se passait peut-être
pendant ces périodes là on sera on sera
encore accusé
Justine je te sens très très ému de tout
ce qui se passe quand même aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que tu aimerais qui qui se
passe parce que j'ai l'impression que
tous les deux vous êtes
au bout de cette histoire n'en pouvait
plus vous avez dénoncé des drames qui
sont arrivés à Bryan et à sa famille
pendant des années des années et
aujourd'hui c'est vous qui êtes sur le
bon des accusés c'est vous qui êtes
montré du doigt aujourd'hui vous avez
l'impression d'être dans un cauchemar je
me dis c'est pas possible vous dites
tout est contre nous c'est ça c'est ni
plus ni moins en fait et mais je me dis
on essaye de sauver des enfants on a les
preuves à l'appui que ils sont
clairement maltraités et qui vivent un
enfer mais non on défend encore les
parents en disant bah elle était toute
seule
c'est dur de s'occuper toute seule de
temps d'enfant maintenant ce que je peux
aller faire tout simplement
aujourd'hui Brian aujourd'hui tu es je
te dis tu risques d'être condamné pour
violence
bagarre en réunion c'est ça
combien
ça peut être plusieurs années jusqu'à 7
ans de prison bon c'est le maximum
requis comme pour vous donc voilà mais
c'est vrai que vous pouvez vous
retrouver un jour jugé pour cette
affaire que vous avez déjà été condamné
c'est ça
exactement
on a l'impression Brian quand même qu'on
vous fait payer votre passé judiciaire
c'est ça c'est totalement ce qu'on fait
payer puis aujourd'hui vous dites 7 ans
couru mais j'ai encore un an de sursis
probatoire donc j'ai eu rendez-vous avec
le SPIP le service de proba sur une
d'insertion pénitentiaire elle m'a
clairement dit que si je passe en le
jugement il demandait la révocation du
sursis donc ça fait déjà un an sur le
dos elle m'a dit ça serait peut-être une
peine aménageable mais aujourd'hui j'ai
une petite fille on m'a en prison je lui
dis quoi j'ai voulu défendre tes ongles
tes tentes aujourd'hui je suis en prison
pour ça
elle pourra pas grandir pendant son père
donc le dernier mot que je voudrais dire
c'est que je vois que Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur il vient d'ici
quelques minutes et je voudrais que lui
réponde à mes questions c'est lui les
ministres c'est normal parce que a
priori les juges oui donc
j'aimerais avoir un avis c'est toutes
les personnes de système sont aussi
puisque vous avez dit c'est justice
spectacle
l'une des premières fois que je suis
venue moi j'appelle ça une justice
complice donc j'aimerais lui poser si
vous intérieur c'est pas Éric
Dupont-Moretti le minimalisme mais avec
plaisir il sera là dans un instant en
direct Gérald Darmanin donc si vous
voulez rester voilà dans le public pour
lui poser une question à un moment
Gérald Darmanin est tout à fait disposé
à répondre à toutes les questions ce
soir en direct dans face à Baba dans
quelques instants donc Brian vous verrez
dans le public avec Justine en tout cas
merci d'avoir été là et on suit à faire
et on espère vraiment que que voilà
c'est il va pas y arriver d'autres
d'autres drames si vous devez quitter
votre petite fille pour aller en prison
et Justine j'espère que vous aussi vous
allez vous allez remonter la pompe parce
que je vous sens très très affecté quand
même mais le plus triste dans tout ça
c'est parce que je sais que c'est
beaucoup Brian qui risque plus que moi à
l'heure actuelle et je sais que ce soit
pour sa fille comme pour lui et même
pour moi ça serait déchirant en fait